when Enzo first gets Robert in his care
he asks if he's a good man or a bad man
Robert replies that he doesn't know and
while that answer might scare some
people it actually Comforts Enzo in a
later conversation Enzo mentions that
Robert saying he doesn't know if he's
really good or bad anymore actually
proves to him that he's good he believes
that good men don't simply Proclaim that
they're good and that their actions
speak far louder as a vigilante Robert
has always sort of watched the line
between good and evil despite there
being good intentions behind Robert's
actions he generally spares no mercy on
his foes so in this good or bad question
is posed to him his answer is fitting
especially given that he's in sort of a
personal crisis when it's asked Robert
has always resided in a sort of moral
gray area but with it now being directly
posed to him viewers get a better sense
of what his morality means to him by the
end Robert has given the Fresh Start he
felt he could never find which allows
him to put his bad past behind him and
move forward as a better man